[Música]
en mi charla de cortadura cinco minutos
así que voy a contar los otros doce así
que empiezo 1 2 3 4 pueden acompañar 56
faltan 11 minutos
en oración
bueno pero no importa yo tenía menos de
20 años de adolescente estaba en un
boliche con amigos y les dije esta es
una me quiere escribir y todos se
me acaban de risa
obvio yo no recordaba esa situación pero
un amigo hace poco me lo encontré
alguien hoy hace mucho y me lo recordó
lo que sí me acordaba de cada vez que yo
decía que quería ser escritor
esto me preguntaba lo mismo me decían en
casa vivir
el futuro se usa en el futuro con un
anzuelo que muestra la zanahoria hay que
perseguirla el punto que hoy está de
moda decir que hay que vivir el presente
el aquí y ahora de momento yo a eso le
agregó
todo lo precario que tenéis para decir
en el presente
es todo lo precario que está en tu
cabeza si pensás boludeces vas a ser un
boludo
si pensás en genialidad esta vez no seas
un genio pero seguramente tu vida sea
más interesante que la del juego que
está al lado ahora si ese tiempo lo usas
para leer literatura yo creo que está
salvado no porque sea la salvación en sí
misma sino porque leer te genera
preguntas
el punto es que me convocan de acá como
bien dijeron para que habría inspiración
no tradicional y yo al respecto tengo
varias preguntas primero que la
inspiración tradicional lado y según
quién
hace dos meses no sé si fueron dos o más
o menos en méxico se ha presentado un
libro y va cambiando por la calle y me
encontré con un negocio de zara home y
en la vidriera hay una cama dos plazas y
media mantita modositos
ositos todo muy lindo y afuera la
vidriera había dos personas durmiendo en
cajas de cartón tiempo de hay una
inspiración tradicional no quien ve
situaciones similares todos los días
y la naturaleza esta forma de encasillar
hay una foto ahí está una foto no fue
ésta la que yo vi pero la encontré en
internet y me parece interesante para
que la vean
nuestra educación nos hace ver cosas
horrendas todos los días y naturalizar
las y así nos encasillamos
supe que quería ser escritora después
que falleció mi papá después que tuve un
accidente y volvió a caminar a los 6
meses que estuve postrado
después que me fui del país a vivir otro
lado y extrañe el castellano y así
empecé a comunicarme con él empecé a
escribir
y lo primero que me pregunte fue
y que es el escritor
me estoy preguntando no importa
escribir estudiar letras
lo que más me interesó de los hábitos
que cambié para hacer lo que deseaba fue
justamente eso cambiar los hábitos para
hacer lo que deseaba desaprender y re
aprender nos es tal vez la clave de
nuestra existencia
es una clave para ser que nosotros
deseamos y no quien debemos
y comenzar a leer me lleno de preguntas
me lleno de incógnitas sobre todo
modificó la mirada la mirada de un
escritor es distinto a la mirada de todo
tipo de artistas de todo tipo de
personas de todo tipo
sobre todo porque es una mirada que
juzga interpela todos los actos que
hacemos todos los actos que los demás
hacen juzgamos con ojos que intentan
encontrar al menos una verdad que sirva
como anclaje para empezar a crear
buscar tal vez el punto vulnerable de
las cosas
como escritor no le creo nada a nadie de
lo que me dice
no le creo nada
de lo que está planteado como natural
no socialmente aceptado es mercancía y
descreer me hace libre
y para llegar a esta libertad absoluta o
al menos que creo que es absoluta
pasaron diez novelas rechazadas de
manera denigrante en distintas
editoriales pasaron miles de páginas
escritas que fueron solamente prueba y
error y descarte y interpelar y juzgar
con tu mirada
me hizo empezar a reconocer los límites
con la idea de destruirlos de quebrar
los de un poco más allá
viva novena se llama como dijo acá
instrucciones para robar supermercados
tarden muchos años en escribirla y
reconozco que en el tiempo que tarda en
escribirla me sentí libre de todo
prejuicio me sentí libre de toda
interpretación moral y sobre todo me
sentí libre de toda realidad que
encasilla
la libertad no se encuentra en ningún
lado no se compra no se hereda no se
pide no se presta no se actúa se trabaja
somos realmente libres el sistema nos
deja ser libres cuando algo viene y me
dicen yo soy libre tengo mi trabajo
independiente manejo mis propios tiempos
me cago de risa en su cara por qué
aunque los signos de la opresión no se
vean no significa que no estén
y cómo ser libres nos tratamos una
pareja creyendo dos enamorados
nos tratamos un trabajo insignificante
con la excusa de pobreza de progreso nos
atamos a el dinero con la excusa de
bienestar
nos atamos a nuestro miedo porque
desatarse significa estar en carne viva
ustedes se van gastan en carne viva
y yo no
a veces sí depende
la libertad yo de manera racional en la
poesía y en la literatura y en la
medicina y en la política y en el
marketing y en la economía ni siquiera
si soy estudiante y menos mucho menos si
no tenés nada no me refiero a poco me
refiero a nada la gente que no tiene
nada no puede pensar en una charla tecno
puede pensar en estudiar apenas puede
pensar en comer o darle comer a sus
hijos
es una pavada pero como dije antes
cuando lo dije lo digo ahora el sistema
premia a los que pueden comprar la cama
en zara home
la meritocracia nos hace ser
un poco peor personas hay que hay que
hacer un poco el bien sin esperar nada a
cambio
vas a vivir pregunta siempre es la
gracia que me preguntaban por qué era la
pregunta tipo escritor y vas a vivir
los escritores trabajamos en la sombra
años y años observando con ojos diáfanos
cargados de dudas ojos como linternas
con poca batería que leen y leen con el
objetivo de iluminar las situaciones más
rebuscadas del mundo con esa mirada
taciturno que intenta comprenderlo todo
que intenta descifrar los intersticios
entre lo que creemos lo que pensamos y
lo que hacemos usamos las palabras
solamente las palabras para crear
personajes que viven en un mundo de
peripecias
ser escritor es estar condenado pero es
la condena más gloriosa más hermosa que
conozco porque definitiva todos
estábamos condenados estamos condenados
a producir
el sistema te condena a producir
y solo quiero leer y si solo quiero
estudiar con mis propios libros y nuevos
métodos y si solo quiero ser un monje y
sentarme de una montaña a meditar en el
resto de mi vida hoy te dicen vago
el fracaso está presente como algo
negativo pero el fracaso del quilombo de
los mambos surgen los gérmenes la basura
la mugre
yo creo que el que no se revolcó alguna
vez en la nunca va a poder
brillar
buen baño para esta noche
porque la inspiración tradicional no es
un germen que se pega en la piel son
semillas que te tragas y crecen y salen
en forma de plantas exóticas a través de
tus dedos al teclado y te seca en la
garganta
se agrieta en los huesos
estéticas de aspirado
de pasando de esas cosas
y sólo puedes puedes pensar en eso y eso
es la gloria
cuando una idea te toma la vida es la
mejor vida que puedes llegar a vivir sin
embargo hay que ser bastante críticos
con las ideas de cada uno hay que saber
profundizar en las ideas eso se logra
con conocimiento
incluso hay que que las ideas propias
cuando tus amigos te dicen que no va a
funcionar cuando tu familia te dice que
es contador o seas abogado o sigas en el
negocio que armó papá
o incluso cuando una pareja de trabajo
por mí va a ser menos
o cuando los gobiernos solo se importan
a llenarse de riqueza
el gobierno desea hablar de mi vida tuve
muchas ideas algunas salieron de
momentos de y otros momentos
gratos pero siempre me detuve a pensar
en ellas analizarlas
porque una idea
como como la intuición quizás son la
antorcha de poderes es un polvo con amor
hace 12 años tuvo una idea que se me
pegó
y la única premisa era sacar el escritor
aunque sea por un rato de la soledad de
la escritura
que pueda ser un escritor para brillar
escribir bien no es suficiente hay
cientos de casos escritores maravillosos
que en vida pasaron sin pena ni gloria
melville por ejemplo
escribió mobydick
y en vida móvil vendió 500 ejemplares y
medio y terminó trabajando en una aduana
hicieron falta varias generaciones para
que se descubra su genialidad y después
hay dos casos que yo rodolfo walsh de
operación masacre escribe una carta de
junta militar y terminó muerto con un
perro y así muchos ya todo esto en la
literatura cada vez se le ve menos
entonces pensé quiero poder escritor
aunque sea como un rato en el centro de
la escena que se luzcan por lo que mejor
hacen
hace 12 años no existía el término
emprendedor hoy está de moda hace 12
años a nadie se le había ocurrido
enchufar una computadora a una pantalla
de un cine y que la gente pueda leer en
vivo a su escritor preferido
así nació en champ el sant de escritura
de la oscuridad
de la tristeza ponele de la soledad
pero sobre todo nació con la idea de que
la gente pueda leer un poco más
y un público que no es lector empieza a
leer los primeros jan de escritura yo no
los hice ni en librerías ni en
bibliotecas y en eventos relacionados a
las letras los primeros son
escrituración nos dicen boliches
como cada escritor es medio un boliche
para que el escritor escriba y la gente
mientras bailaba iba leyendo y sabía que
estaba leyendo pero veía y sentía
inspirada y hacía cosas y se iba tardes
con ganas de leer un poco más
y así fue creciendo como un germen como
como el personaje una novela que de
pronto lo vas escribiendo y se desliga
del autor y pide cosas
elián fue pidiendo cosas él llamó
detiene se estable en españa en méxico
se hicieron más de 300 eventos en todo
el mundo luego más de 300 escritores
también se crió más escribió miles de
páginas pero siguió estuviste
no es leíste el jam es un evento único e
irrepetible no hubo un evento igual a
otro cada escritor que viene le pone su
impronta cada cruce con escritor e
ilustrador y música es absolutamente
distinto es casi mágico yo lo siento así
ojalá algún día pueden algunos hacerlo
y de una simbiosis única entre el autor
el texto la música la ilustración y el
público que se convierte en lector
instantáneo
y vive en un evento que existió de ese
presente que ya no existe
y que todo el mundo se perdió
me hubiese gustado poder responder
cuando era más joven y me preguntaban de
qué vas a vivir
de respirar de comer de al baño de tomar
agua
le hubiese dicho
no sé de qué voy a vivir último vídeo
voy a vivir de algo que todavía no
inventé voy a inventar
y de mejoras más porque en definitiva mi
vida
porque quizá lo mejor todavía no está
inventado las mejores novelas no se
escribieron y quizás surjan de la basura
y ustedes yo les preguntaría qué van a
vivir por ahora que no importa lo que sí
me puede importar es que una vez por mes
a al menos vaya a una librería busquen a
un autor argentino contemporáneo y
complete un libro de alguien que está
que lo puede encontrar mañana
si no les gusta nos regalan y si les
gusta lo recomiendan muchas gracias
tres minutos así que si no contando
quedamos en 8 9 10